going into the final leg of the grand
chest or how do you feel you've
performed up to this point and how do
you hope that you're going to finish uh
well i didn't play well in romania
i scored 50
but
the quality wasn't there and the result
wasn't enough you know to garner many
grand chess tour points
as for uh
the singfield cup
yeah my classical play has been pretty
poor recently so i'm hoping to recover
from that my last result wasn't great i
didn't do
very well in in zagreb although i i was
preparing quite
quite well and i was
doing my best but
it didn't go well
the first one was was quite decent in
in romania so yeah the plan is just to
finish well
for me it's not a big chance to
to to be in top three in this
time last year i played much better i
will just see like his very super
tournament and i will try to play good
chess interesting chance
and try to play
much better than first two
tournaments i mean in zagreb and
in bucharest
i've performed well in terms of points
for sure because
i am
among first three players
having
played a few events so
you know
i have a good feeling that i could do
well
now with that being said
the way i played was not always that
convincing in boss bucharest and tag web
so i worked up a lot of points
but i feel like i will have to play
still even better you know to
to take it in archer
yeah i performed um not very well i
think this throughout the tour but i
have a feeling i could improve my
results in the tour by playing here
i think i have a great chance i played
well in zagreb but in romania i didn't
play so good so
i'm looking forward to improving my
performance here
frankly i don't even know what is my
like status right now like how many
points the tour points do i have i
assume not so much because i did quite
poorly in bucharest as it seems after
madrid it was more or less for the for
the battery you had to have some nice
training so here of course it would be
not about training what about
i hope it would be about like achieving
some high result and uh yeah
i'll try to
try to fight as hard as i can
there's a lot of competition this year
compared to last year
players have brought a lot fearlessly
just won a big tournament also maximum
is playing really well
in order to fight for standings you can
have to win some games like plus one
plus two
probably plus three is enough to win the
same field cup but
we'll see what happens
just like to take it
a game at a time try to
come to the games very well rested and
try to play well and see
where things go
well i've had a lot of experience
against these guys and let's see rapid
and blitz events online events so
i feel like i know these people quite
well and uh um
i don't necessarily feel like um
i'm completely that inferior to them so
i'm just looking to to show my my my
best chest and and to show that uh i can
compete on an equal level with the top
players in the world and uh
as long as i show that then i'm sure
that
don't be the
you know last thingfield cap that i play
i'm
[Music]
more or less satisfied because i'm in
the contention so
yeah
i really would like to win it because i
never won
gct tour
and
i always like collecting new victories
[Music]